valérie plante avait promis de faire de
la politique autrement avec son premier
budget est ce vraiment le cas la
mairesse dit avoir rempli sa promesse de
ne pas augmenter les taxes
au delà de l'inflation pour l'engagement
de la taxe foncière non ce genre appelle
ça a été ça a été respectée et en 2014
denis coderre avait dit exactement la
même chose
c'en est nu 1,1 véhicules neufs donc on
a on a rempli notre promesse
les deux ont utilisé la même approche
évitez de spécifier qu'avec les taxe
d'arrondissement par exemple le fardeau
fiscal des montréalais augmentait plus
vite que l'inflation 2,8 pour cent dans
le premier budget de monsieur coderre
3,3 pour ça dans le budget de madame
plantes
c'est un budget de transition qui
ressemble énormément au budget de
transition qui avait été mis en place en
l'administration plantes d'auray a
d'abord cherché à minimiser l'impact de
cette hausse de taxe sur les montréalais
comment est-ce que 118 dollars j'allais
faire mal aux montréalais et bien encore
là c'est l'histoire qui se répète
l'administration tremblay-applebaum a
fait exactement la même chose en 2011
michael applebaum quitte à l'époque
président du comité exécutif avait dit
qu'une augmentation d'environ 100
dollars en moyenne par année
c'était plus que raisonnable en 2005
gerald tremblay a brisé sa promesse de
geler les taxes des montréalais
j'ai branly sans le vouloir le lien de
confiance que j'avais établi avec la
population je le regrette
il ya devant la grogne populaire gérard
tremblay lui a fait marche arrière et
offert finalement un gel de taxes
tel que promis